some of you might want to present what
happens over time with your photographs
other than creating a video it's usually
quite compelling when watching a dynamic
phenomena it's true and if you think
about it all of science is ultimately
dynamic right things change over time we
generally assume one has to watch a
moving image to see that change so here
for example you are seeing something
called the Bellas augs Abbott in skoo
reaction it's a complicated oscillating
reaction that we're observing within a
petri dish but it's not a video in the
sense that it wasn't taken with a video
camera you're seeing a series of still
images that I made and I was privileged
to make in professor jabotinsky slab at
brandeis I took the images 11 seconds
apart over a period of five minutes by
the way I made the images in film which
became slide formats as you might
remember or then again maybe you don't
and you're seeing digital scans of those
individual frames we're seeing the
spiral waves forming a color indicator
allows us to see the reaction so what
we're really seeing is a series of still
images one right after the other that is
in fact what a moving image is isn't it
so that looks pretty interesting but in
my opinion just as interesting is seeing
the individual images lined up in a grid
so that we can compare one image to the
other and note the changes that occur I
am convinced there is a place for this
kind of presentation here's another
example you're looking at a one
centimeter across circular sandwich
let's call it of two pieces of glass the
glass contains within the sandwich
material called block copolymers in a
solvent and over time the solvent
evaporates around the edges so that over
time the block copolymers
self assemble in different orientations
and that change is visually translated
into changes in color and so again we're
seeing a series of stills one right
after the other viewing it as a moving
image but here too looking at each side
by side can clarify exactly what is
going on I just want you to think a
little bit about seeing a series of
stills instead of only an animation by
the way here is that still image in the
journal let's talk a little bit about
showing scale in your presentations my
purpose here is to nudge you to think a
little differently from perpetuating the
standard approach to showing scale
within an image instead of for example
showing that overused coin side by side
with your device how about making the
composition ever so slightly more
interesting you can also think about
showing your device on top of something
other than a coin for example something
more recognizable and more interesting
in structure in this case I use a
compact disc which might not be familiar
from years to come but I'm trying it
here anyway I hope you still know what
it is and in the caption we can give
more information about the size of the
device or the material and here we're
seeing an image of a structure giving
the reader both a sense of scale and
property the presence of the coins
suggests the scale of the small objects
but we're also seeing that the structure
itself can collapse and then bounce back
which is in fact the important part of
what this is about in this image which
will see again in week six you're seeing
a syringe needle which I used to place
some colored water onto a surface it's a
suggestion of the scale of the square
drops of water it isn't quantitative but
just a hint of a size if you know the
size of a syringe needle and another way
you might present an idea of scale is to
show something from various points of
view as we zoom into the material so
here is that
old computer memory core we saw before
something I'll bet most of you haven't
seen before this class and in the next
image I made the picture with a 105 lens
getting closer to the material and again
here I'm coming even closer with another
tool something called a stereomicroscope
once again even getting closer with a
compound microscope and finally I made
an image with a scanning electron
microscope which I've colored so yes
it's true I'm not exactly showing you
the exact size of the material but I'm
taking you sort of through a sense of
scale and maybe sort of telling a scale
story the same with this morpho
butterfly wing as we zoom into the
structure first taken with a camera and
lens then getting closer to the material
looking with a colored scanning electron
micrograph we see more detail and even
getting more enlarged seeing it with
another standing electron micrograph
which I colored now it appears blue
initially but there's no blue dye
presence the color is due to the
structure of the wing which is what
we're seeing and it's an interesting
story which I suggest you look into
here's another idea instead of always
placing a scale bar either in the lower
right-hand corner or the lower left-hand
corner how about if we place the scale
bar within the image in a more designed
approach you just did see an example of
this and here's another example I've
placed and labeled the scale bar within
the image the full design of the image
works better the information is there
but doesn't compromise the aesthetics of
the image the scale bar works with it
and the same with this image which
you've also seen before the bar doesn't
always have to be on the bottom right or
left unless of course the journal
insists on that there is no reason why
it has to be placed in that format
that's one of those perpetuated rules
that in my opinion have
no logic to it for our book on the
surface of things we wanted to suggest a
comparative sense of scale when looking
at all of the images in the book we used
the head of a pin which measures about
between one to two millimeters as a
reference point next to each image you
see a blue outline of a pinhead made
relative to the size of what's in the
photograph so for example looking at
this image of ferrofluid the pinhead
appears around this size note the blue
circle but when we have to zoom way down
to the nano scale level in order to see
the indentations of this compact disc
the pinhead circle almost becomes a
straight line we hardly see the
curvature because the indented areas are
so small we cannot use photons to image
that surface we have to use electrons
with a scanning electron microscope so
just imagine traveling down to that nano
scale while the pinhead enlarges as you
pass it by I think it worked quite well
for the book hope you do